while the coronavirus gets most of the  attention in washington the biden  administration is also addressing  immigration reform  new homeland security secretary  alejandro mayorkas is the first  immigrant to hold the cabinet post he  was sworn in yesterday  president biden says he wants to  overturn what he calls bad policies left  over from the trump administration  a new executive order undoes the family  separation policy from former president  trump  mr biden also created a new task force  to begin reuniting more than 600  children with children with their  parents  we're going to work to undo the moral  and national shame  of the previous administration other  orders will review the requirement for  thousands of asylum seekers to stay in  mexico  while their cases are processed here in  the u.s